would you rather live in a world without  headphones or a world without doors i'm  gonna say a world without  doors or if someone's in my house it's  fine like  really yeah we're friends  i don't have doors in my apartment well  i have a bathroom door but i have like a  like a straight shot like a like a  railroad apartment so i don't have doors  yeah i mean actually you're right  because if i was  like in a relationship or married or  something and i had to go to the  bathroom i would just have to leave the  country yeah  so okay  uh headphones can i tell you guys  something my parents have never farted  in front of each other and they've been  together for 45 years  man yeah people the couple that shits  together and parks together does not  it's too close right and they're always  convincing you like no we're cool like  we're the cool people it's like okay you  guys are weird